bonjour jean marc bonjour ma gueule et
heureuse de vous retrouver dans cette
matinale rt france alors il ya une
dimension dont on ne parle pas beaucoup
quand il ya des risques de conflits
armés la dimension économique qu'en est
il exactement dans ce cas précis jean
marc c'est la crise sur l'ukraine bond
alimenté par des rivalités politiques
culturelles vous avais parlé il ya un
instant des considérations géopolitiques
aussi mais derrière tout ça vous avez
raison il ya des intérêts économiques
qui sont de nature soit aggraver les
risques soit calmé le jeu et je crois
qu'on est arrivé à un point de tension
où les risques économiques sont pris en
compte par toutes les parties pourquoi
et bien tout simplement parce qu'en cas
d'intervention militaire en ukraine on
sait très bien que les états unis
infligerait des sanctions économiques à
la russie l'ont dit et répété ils ont
même écrit en bloquant toutes les
relations commerciales et financières et
pour l'europe ce serait très vite
insupportable les relations économiques
entre la russie et l'europe sont
nombreuses elles sont lourdes en dépit
des difficultés politiques des pressions
chinoises parce que les chinois sont
derrière la russie a toujours été le
premier client fournisseur aussi des
européens et réciproquement l'europe a
perdu des parts de marché au profit de
la russie au prophète de la chine
d'ailleurs mais la russie est resté est
restée le premier fournisseur de gaz de
l'europe un gaz qui est acheminée via
les gazoducs dont le fameux nord stream
1 qui traverse la baltique et qui relie
saint pétersbourg à l'allemagne du nord
un gazoduc qui devrait d'ailleurs être
doublé par un hors stream 2 mais dont la
mise en service a déjà pris du retard à
cause des tensions diplomatiques entre
moscou et bruxelles est actuellement
l'europe importe 40% de sa consommation
de gaz aux russes ça pourrait d'ailleurs
pratiquement doublé très rapidement avec
le nord ce thème de l'europe importe 20%
de sa consommation à la norvège pour le
reste et le reste c'est la la
consommation urbain provient dans des
conditions compliquées cher du reste du
monde dont 1 % environ des états unis
donc nous sommes très dépendants du gaz
russe comme nous le sommes d'ailleurs du
pétrole d'arabie saoudite pour pour le
diesel blocage qu'est ce qui pourrait
bien se passait pas très simple les
européens n'auraient plus de gaz elle
serait obligée d'en trouver ailleurs
notamment aux états unis qui attendent
ça avec un peu de vous 10 même s'il n'en
parle pas beaucoup l'amérique du nord
les états unis le canada se déclare
parfaitement en mesure de remplacer le
gaz russe pour approvisionner les
chaudières et les foyers européens cela
dit tout le monde sait bien que ce grand
remplacement seraient affreusement
compliquée à mettre en oeuvre d'abord
parce que le gaz américain est un gaz de
schiste qu'il faut évidemment extraire
dans les conditions très polluante
d'autant que le gaz russe lui et sans
doute beaucoup plus d'écart décarbonés
que le gaz américain grâce d'ailleurs à
des entreprises françaises parce que
total il travaille énormément ensuite le
gaz américain est difficile à
transporter il faut liquéfié ce gaz le
mettre sur des bateaux pour traverser
l'atlantique alors que pour le gaz russe
il suffit d'ouvrir les robinets et
d'utiliser les gazoducs enfin au total y
appuyait le prix parce qu'à un arrêt des
approvisionnements russes ben
provoquerait une crise de l'énergie
ferait exploser les prix pref je ne
crois pas qu'on puisse remplacer le gaz
russe en europe mais l'inversé est vrai
aussi la russie a besoin de vendre son
gaz parce que c'est sa principale
richesse s'aperçut pas source de revenus
donc l'europe a intérêt à trouver un
compromis de paix d'autant qu'il n'y a
pas que la question du gaz qui seraient
bloqués vous avez à peu près 600
entreprises européennes qui travaillent
en russie bon pour les français on
connaît total mais il ya danone par
exemple aussi donc c'est un partenaire
historique mais il y en a beaucoup d'eau
dans l'agroalimentaire et oui dans la
mécanique les allemands les italiens
sont concernés aussi hélas réussi a
besoin de toutes ces entreprises donc
sans le dire vladimir poutine a intérêt
à lui aussi à trouver un compromis quant
à l'ukraine elle a besoin et de la
russie et de l'europe alors en arrivant
à moscou mm macro savait parfaitement
cette réalité en clair la réalité fige
le statu quo la réalité économique
plaident pour que tout ça soit fait afin
d'éviter un conflit armé en ukraine mais
cette réalité ne dit pas ce qu'il
faudrait faire pour faire baisser la
tension et pourra arrêter le bras de fer
en attendant russes et français savent
qu'ils ont fait baisser la tension un
petit peu donc cette initiative macron
de médiation n'était peut-être pas
inutile merci beaucoup jean-marc pour
toutes ces précisions on s'était l'édito
échos de la matinale